madame et bonjour bonjour madame carle
et pau là mais vous savez vous êtes très
apprécié vous êtes même c'est vous qui
avez le plus la confiance des
participants à notre boussole électorale
ex aequo avec le chef du npd thomas
mulcair
et pourtant votre parti n'arrive pas à
avoir plus que 5 6 % d'appuis pourquoi
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui vous empêche
de faire une percée nous avons augmenté
le niveau d'appui mais c'est dans les
régions locales au niveau national c'est
vraiment difficile de fait les bons
sondages plus de 6 à 6 7%
mais est-ce que c'est pas le fait qu'il
ya d'autres partis maintenant qu'ils
défendent aussi l'environnement
chaque partie enfin je pense aux
libéraux néo-démocrates au bloc ont une
plateforme environnementale
ça vient un peu vous couper l'herbe sous
thil ont n'ont malheureusement l'autre
partie seulement les les plateformes
très faible et c'est seulement le bloc
québécois qui sont d'accord avec le
parti des rencontres les pipelines comme
angie a c'est vrai mais et c'est un
grand avantage d'avoir les députés verts
ton échanges techniques pour le québec
et pour les québécoises et québécois
parce que nous sommes à partie avec les
députés dans les autres provinces aussi
et quand un était un avion engagé à
arrêter ces piscines pour pour arrêter
le croissance de sable de petites
minières c'est nécessaire de mettre sur
pied un stratégie énergétique nationale
et vous pensez que c'est mieux pour les
environnementalistes d'être dans un
parti vert comme le vôtre qui n'aspire
pas à prendre le pouvoir que d'être dans
un parti qui justement peut peut être
gouvernée c'est comme si vous étiez
postes sur la patinoire vous êtes à côté
de la patinoire pour pour nous nous
pensons maintenant c'est le moment de
père c'est parce que actuellement nous
avons les sondages qui indiquent un
parlement minoritaire elle dans un
parlement minoritaire
le parti vert et les députés verts ont
le pouvoir tester les grands changements
peut-être peut-être nous allons avoir le
bal ans de pouvoir avec les capitales
oui c'est pas si c'est monsieur harper
qui obtient un gouvernement minoritaire
vous avez déjà dit que vous et vous irez
voir le gouverneur général pour lui dire
de ne pas lui permettre de former le
gouvernement mais est ce que c'est
possible c'est vraiment possible parce
que dans notre système parlementaire
mais le haras le première essai mais ce
n'est pas clair que si je fais l'effort
de parler avec le gouverneur général et
aussi avec les autres chefs des autres
partis
le moqueur et monsieur rouleau est dit
que 21 minutes s'il vous plaît donnez
nous comme un groupe de députés un
groupe de chefs des autres partis
l'occasion de parler l'autre pour
trouver s'il est possible de travailler
ensemble travail pour trouver une façon
de travailler ensemble comme pas
vraiment comment collection officielle
c'est possible mais pour trouver un pape
allemand de rab le scap plus efficace et
pourquoi vous ne donniez pas une chance
à monsieur harper d'essayer au moins de
gouverner c'est un décennie de
destruction avec monsieur après la
destruction de nos lois pour la
protection d'environnement destruction
de notre approche pour les justice
criminelle pour justice sociaux cds pas
acceptable d'imaginer un autre minutes
avec monsieur rappelle qu'un prémice si
on est est comme nous engager pour la
protection d'environnement et pour
une négociation à paris qui sont qui le
début des négociations à paris sur
quarante jours après les élections
nous n'avons point ne va pas le temps
pour me charles cros faire des essais
dans le parlement avec un gouvernement
minoritaire
mais c'est essentiel pour le canada de
prendre aux traditionnelles de d2 dans
le monde et quel est le parti dont vous
êtes le plus proche alors quel est le
parti qui a la meilleure plateforme
environnementale pouvait pour tous les
autres sont faibles c'est vrai tous les
autres sont meilleurs de monsieur harper
c'est je pense que c'est à eux après les
élections on regarde tous les députés
aient pensé en négociation avec les
autres c'est monsieur trudeau où
monsieur moquer pour moi c'est fait pas
de déficit travaillé avec lui de l'aps
éléments je vais vous poser une question
sur le port du niqab
parce que vous savez que c'est en train
de dominer tout le débat de cette
campagne électorale depuis plusieurs
jours donc le parti vert est d'accord ou
contre le port du niqab lors des
cérémonies d'assermentation oui c'est un
faux débat ça c'est vraiment fou parce
que et il y a eu qu'une enfance de
prendre l'engagement citoyen à visage
découvert c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
un tour pas du tout et ce n'est pas aux
zones de décider ce que les femmes
doivent porter ou pensez vous décider je
pense que c'est un faux débat et
j'espère que on peut parler des sujets
importants comme choses soient
climatique comme l'association même les
brader chose de très symbolique quand
même dans une cérémonie d'assermentation
quand on devient citoyen
il n'y a pas de bénéfice pour quelqu'un
qui qui était avec un visage couvert
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que c'est
le problème avec ça je comprends pas
pourquoi c'est mais c'est avec le
cynisme de monsieur harper avec son
capteur était de créer les débats avec
beaucoup aimé aussi émotion quelques
peurs l'un contre l'autre c'était une
opération politique parce que monsieur
rappeuse se présente comme un défenseur
des femmes où ils en sont oui mais ce
n'est pas pour lui elle peut décider de
ce que les femmes doivent porter
mesurera pour ce n'est pas il n'est pas
quelqu'un qui ait fait le grand lutte
pour les droits des femmes au contraire
autour du canada nous avons l'équipe des
questions de violence contre les femmes
mais je rai uno rai le demande d'avoir
un inquiète pour les femmes autochtones
qui sont m alors s'est il n'est pas
quelqu'un féministes pour protéger les
droits des femmes le franchement merci
beaucoup madame et merci